I'm Mark Campana.
I'm 41 years old, and
I'm from Akron, Ohio.
My day job is personal trainer.
When I'm not training
other people, I'm at home,
and I'm making knives.
I have made probably
over 200 knives.
And that doesn't include the
pile that nobody gets to see.
I'm pretty confident
that I could win.
Honestly, the hardest part
for this competition for me
isn't going to be
any of the obstacles.
It's going to be me.
Who made this knife?
I made it.
This is a beast of a
blade, but it's not unwieldy.
Do you have a weight on this?
I have no idea.
I just know that
it is not light.
What have you got here?
Just an etching.
Honestly, it doesn't
mean anything.
I just think it looks cool.
You know, sometimes that's
on purpose all of itself.
That's it.
Excited to see you swing it.
I'm excited myself.
This is a plastic
tube filled with wax.
And it can very easily shatter.
And this is a lot of
blade to slow down.
It's not that this blade
will have any difficulty
generating the power.
It's that I know I'm going
to contact a light object,
and I've to be able to
bring it to a safe stop.
Good luck, because your
knife makes the cut.
Thank you.
I'm absolutely ready
to face Knife Fight.
I'm going to destroy it.
NARRATOR: Next up, Mark Cantana.
I tell you what,
this personal trainer
with this big, bad blade
is looking for victims
as he steps up to Knife Fight.
This is a modified
chopper, 16 and 1/2 inches,
three pounds of cutting power.
It will chop like an axe.
Let's talk about power.
As he steps up
the trifecta, he's
going to have to be powerful.
One strike right
through the rope.
Look how he drops his
balance he dops his base.
He's a personal trainer.
He knows body mechanics.
But this is technique.
He's not really making that--
Boom!
He broke the apparatus
holding the two-by-four.
That's a penalty.
He has to cut the object in
half, and he did not do that.
He broke the chain.
One penalty.
If you just use proper
technique with that power,
he will cut through, no problem.
Just like that, boom, right
through the last two-by-four.
He's moving on to box cutter.
Wow.
I like how he's dug
up on his handle.
But look at that power.
That blade almost split
the box halfway through.
Look at his accuracy.
He's able to hit the box
almost in the same area.
He is fierce.
Boom!
Tell you what, that might
be the hardest strike
those boxes have taken off.
Moving on to the second box.
Oh, powerful strike
right into that box.
Look at that power!
He's very calculated.
He waits for the proper time for
that box to get in the position
that he employs power.
Boom!
There he goes.
He's moving on.
Next up, the Decapitator.
We've seen a lot of
people fail at this.
This definitely is
a hard apparatus.
I like how he's taking his
time, studying the objects.
Notice how he's using
his hip line now.
Uh oh.
Took his eyes off the
last couple of targets.
Now he has to get it
completely horizontal.
He's got to concentrate
on the follow-through,
keep it straight.
OK, he got it.
- Nice.
Now he adjusts his accuracy.
He went right through it.
Beautiful job.
Steps up to Thrice.
He should be able to
punch through this ice
block, no issue.
That blade, the
geometry is there.
Wow.
Two slices right
through the first block.
Look at that power.
One slice right
through the second,m
and right through the third.
Beautiful job.
Mark Campana destroys Thrice.
Moving on-- Lifeline.
It's all about angles,
attack, and accuracy.
Remember-- one strike
through, or you're going home.
Boom, right through the chicken.
He's got to take his time.
He's studying the objective.
That he is.
A proper base.
Boom, right through,
great Follow-through OK,
cut the rope.
This is hard.
He needs to hit with speed.
Very quick.
Oh!
Taken down by the
two-edged rope.
He had the proper blade.
He has proper strength.
But I think he went
about it wrong.
It's all about coming
in at a steep angle
to let gravity take
over, and then speed.
Unfortunately, that's
not what he did there.
My knife can cut the rope.
It was my technique that screwed
me up on that last thing.